[Music]
good morning my name is Colleen Shogun I
work at the Library of Congress the
assistant deputy librarian for
collections and services and I'm pleased
to be here this morning to talk to you
about some exciting new work that we're
working on here at the Library of
Congress in Washington DC and in
particular I'm here to talk to you about
the National Library Service for the
blind and physically handicapped which
is a program and division within the
Library of Congress and what I'll refer
to that's a very long name for a program
but I'll refer to it going forward as
simply nls and that's what we refer to
it as well here to give you an overview
I'm not by the way I'm a political
scientist I'm not technologist or an
engineer but I'm here to give you an
overview of NLS and this unique program
within the federal government as the
slide says nls has has been in existence
since 1931 and the vision of nls the
vision statement is so that all may read
what analysts is is a free program for
those who are visually impaired or
print-disabled to provide what you would
call audio books what we call talking
books to United States citizens all
across the country and NLS to talk to
you a little bit about it there's about
a hundred people a little bit over a
hundred people who work at NLS like I
said it is a program or division within
the Library of Congress it's located in
the Petworth neighborhood of Washington
DC so a little bit apart from where the
main Library of Congress campus is
situated on Capitol Hill it has its own
appropriation it has its own funding
within the federal government part of
the Library of Congress but
separate appropriation that's dedicated
specifically for books for the blind and
print disabled and currently right now
NLS receives about 53 million dollars a
year in which to do this right now n LS
and this is what I'm going to talk a
little bit about the distribution of
those audiobooks are talking books is
done both through an analog so physical
delivery through the United States
Postal Service and also through digital
delivery and that's how the program
works right now here's a few statistics
about NLS I'll talk a little bit give
you a little bit about the overview and
then I want to talk to you about how NLS
works this is a little misleading it
says that there's nine hundred seventy
some thousand accounts that really
translates into about four hundred and
fifty thousand users across the United
States and in addition to these users
there are about a hundred Network
libraries that partner with the Library
of Congress in which to distribute these
books and this is how it works
so if you sign up for the NL s service
and you are eligible once you're
determined that you are eligible for the
program you receive an account you also
receive what we call a digital talking
books machine in which you can play
analog delivery of these talking books
which is essentially a thumb drive that
is sent to your to your home you could
also bring your own device and download
the books digitally through our online
website which is called bard so those
are the two ways that you're able to get
your books right now either way whether
you receive your books digitally or
whether you receive them in the mail to
play them on your digital talking books
machine most of our users rely upon the
librarians at those 100 Network
libraries for assistance in deciding
what books they want to listen to and
curating the list of books that are in
their queue to be read
now I'd like to talk a little bit about
where we're headed so that's where we
are right now it's a very successful
program it's a very popular program with
obviously our users the visually
impaired community and also with
Congress but this is where we're headed
we are embarking into a very exciting
time I think in LSE's history the
Library of Congress's history we're
undertaking a modernization effort for
the next five to seven years and the
goal of this modernization effort is to
move NLS from a predominantly analog
service right now about 90% of our users
receive their books in the mail from the
US Postal Service to a predominantly
digital service so that's where we are
right now and that's where we want to
head there are some challenges with that
because of course any changes we want to
make in the delivery of our talking
books has to take into account our users
and as you might imagine with a visually
impaired community of users most of our
users skew towards the older age
spectrum so we're very sensitive about
creating and taking advantage of
technologies that will be acceptable and
can be used by our patrons and the
people who rely upon us for books
we do have a aggressive strategy in the
next five to seven years as I said
before we have currently about 450,000
users across the United States we would
like to increase that to 1 million users
across the United States in the next
five to seven years as the result of
modernization and really what we're
talking about is elevating digital
experiences and what that means to
myself and how I think about that is
that I my vision is for NLS users to be
able to consume talking books and read
books the same way that you or I are
used to consuming books and that means
being able to download and have access
to books on demand if you hear about a
book on TV or the radio
or you hear about it from a friend
you're able to download that book if you
read digitally you're able to download
that book immediately and then take in
and begin reading it if you so choose if
you don't like that book or it's not
what you expected you're able to switch
streams and download a different book
immediately and start that book and
having the ability to be able to do that
as for myself as a reader has really
changed the way I consume books and it
makes for a much more enriching
experience and that's the vision that we
want to bring to our
nls users right now not that they
necessarily have to wait three to five
days for that for that cartridge to come
in the mail but that they're able to
have access to those audiobooks right
now online and where we're headed is
relying primarily on a bring your own
device model in the future with perhaps
a digital talking book machine that's
provided to those users who need it and
we definitely want to move to a
technology that's platform agnostic so
that we can have people that bring the
devices that they're comfortable with be
able to use them and take advantage of
nls services and what we're doing right
now is NLS is in the very early stages
we're really in year zero of this
modernization effort with it kicking off
next year and what we're doing right now
is doing small pilot projects to figure
out which technologies can best serve
our user and patron base in the future
and that brings us to the subject of
today's presentation which is focused on
the voice user interface which is one of
the pilot projects that an analyst is
engaged in this year so trying to figure
out how can we use voice user interface
in the future for our patrons who want
to search for a book for example I want
to read biographies I want to read
romances I want to read westerns how can
they have that interactive experience
working with artificial intelligence
with a voice user interface that will
enable them to get the right books in
their cue
and that they will be able to enjoy they
also need to be able to listen to those
books most of our patrons will listen to
a book from start to finish for example
how you might read a fiction book or
even most nonfiction books but other
users will want particular books in
which they need to skip around so you
have to be able to use the voice
automated interface to be able to move
to different points in the book for
example if you were reading a recipe or
a cookbook or if you're reading a travel
book are good examples where you
wouldn't read that book necessarily
sequentially but focusing on particular
parts of the book that you find
interesting or relevant so right now
where the library is and we're gonna see
a demo here from some of my colleagues
that I think is very promising
right now where the Library of Congress
is we've issued an RFI request for
information about search discovery and
playback for audio books for the
visually impaired using smart speaker
technology on a vendor vendor agnostic
platform and that's just our process of
gathering more information in this very
early pre stage of modernization so that
we're able to make the best strategic
decisions in the future for the
modernization of our services to the
blind visually impaired and print
disabled it's also important for us I
will say the last thing that's important
for us is security because the national
library service of the blind and
physically handicapped has an exception
to legislation to copyright provisions
that enable them to share books to the
users of the NLS community but we want
to make sure that whenever we put these
books out there that only our NLS users
are being authorized to listen and take
advantage of them so security is also of
utmost importance for us and also to our
patrons so now I'm going to turn it over
to my colleagues who are going to talk a
little bit about their work their
technical work in this area that they've
done already and they will also show us
a demo which is really a product of all
their hard work
thanks : good morning everyone my name
is Prabhu Palani Sami
I'm from the spring ml team we had the
privilege of working with the Library of
Congress in building the pilot and demo
associated with it
show of hands I'll pretend that I will
be able to see how many of you in the
room has a smartphone how many of you
have a Google home or a device in your
house how many of you have more than one
device that's the age we live in right
like obviously parents in the room knows
how their kids are able to make use of
the Google homes effectively than us
wise interface is becoming the primary
mode of communication for many of the
applications that are being built today
here is an image of the talking devices
that are being developed and and the
technology enablement happened in waves
innovation wise at Library of Congress
this is was displayed in the in the hall
of the Library of Congress when we were
doing the project so Cassatt record
players and the one in the middle is the
device that is used by the parents today
they have to go to the library they have
to get the right device in place and
then use it to read books like when we
were surveying when on the project they
were patrons who read like three to four
books a week and they read at the pace
of around 1.75 to 2x on a compared to a
normal reader who is reading visually
they play it fast they are able to graph
the content much faster than the rest of
the people to level set right from a
technology project this is a very very
easy for us to map it that's the device
that's the technology that they are
exposed today and
solution is right in front of you guys
like you know having a device that they
can interact over voice and get the
content that they are looking for to
look at it like you know for a photo for
a general audience
we have ebooks that's the primary choice
that we use these days apps Google
assistant mobile app smartphones that we
interact with and again the third one is
the conversational interface that's the
the exposure of technology for for
common people like us and how about
having this technology to the other
folks that we want to you know enable
them like up Colin mentioned they have a
vision of making sure that the the four
hundred thousand folks are getting
enable and getting the value out of it
in simple terms this is the vision we
wanted to implement on a project like
sitting in a home or on evening when
they come back when they say play a book
and the system starts to able to
understand the user profile' goes
through the security the authentication
the the lookup and then the book starts
to play simple terms but imagine for a
moment how powerful the life changes for
folks who can get this value and then
from the the Library of Congress team
how about we do it for all the books the
journals publications where there are
asserts that the team has it and we can
enable it for the folks for a general
audience now we have I think we have set
the stage okay this is the device the
patrons use and this is the end goal
like you know using a conversational
interface and play the books how did we
do it and what are some of these acts
success criterias to consider for a
further project like this number one
it's a conversational it's not like a
resource you click on
button or RRR open a page and go through
and like a normal application it should
be a human conversation hey I'm
interested in a science-fiction book or
I'm interested in a cooking recipe can
you list out the books that are of
interest to me I'm interested in a book
by a specific author or a genre that I
need to look up it needs to be highly
conversational in terms of interaction
voice the other thing is interactive
where it's not about a book and the
system place it how do we make it more
interactive like you know go to the next
chapter pause come back to the the to
the to the to the synopsis of the book
or or read me the the cut title and the
contents we want to make it highly
interactive so that way it's not about
finding the resource and playing the
resource but how would a human converse
and interact with an application the
last and very important one is scale
this is not a project for a certain
subset of people or certain subsets of
books we want to solve it at scale when
we want to load hundred books it should
be the same process to load thousand ten
thousand and a million books imagine for
a moment we solve problems and then in
order to scale it probably enterprise I
consultants or IT in the room would have
gone through the struggle of building a
project is one thing building an
application was the scaling that
applications we want to do it in in one
one platform that supports this
end-to-end pipeline so we thought
further any delay I would like to invite
Amit - Pandey from our Spring Jamel team
to go through the demo of it hello
everyone Thank You Prabhu so you get
into the demo so I'm not sure how many
of you have worked
but all right how many of you actually
worked on a low-flow developers out
there all right
great thanks so what we've done is we've
built a dialogue flow system out here
application and it's right now
in the beta stage like Colleen mentioned
its pilot and we have tried to make sure
that we take care of all the nuances
that the library wanted make sure that
it's scalable it's usable across
multiple platforms right and highly
conversational and all the good stuff
all right let's get started with the
demo so what I'm going to do is unlike
your usual way of talking to Google and
saying hey Google I'm going to trigger
it from hang mobile
so getting an LS bad show welcome to the
library here you can search for books
play books or add them to your
collection for later reading how can I
help can you read a book for me please
specify the title of the book check our
title list if you are unsure okay do you
have books by Winterbotham is it one
move Tarkington
to Deborah Bianco t3 Michael Corita
please choose the number none of them
okay then we have many books from
science fiction to spy fiction to the
autobiographies say your book title
genre or author to learn more what books
on science do you have is it one Lena
said to Jason her three ami sis kind
please choose the number well what about
travel books are available travel books
include one the monk of mocha two
timepieces three familiar bound which
book would you like me to play choose
the book number any more options here
are the additional travel books for
eating eternity food art and literature
in France five I took your romance a
member six the long haul a trucker's
tales of life on the road which one
would you like to hear please say the
book number mmm what about books on food
are available cooking books include one
joy of cooking to the reporters kitchen
three what she ate which book would you
like me to play choose the book number
okay play Pride and Prejudice
is it Pride and Prejudice yes
okay now reading Pride and Prejudice
this is a librivox recording all
librivox recordings are in the public
domain for more information please visit
librivox.org
today's reading Pride and Prejudice by
Jane Austen chapters 1 2 3 red by Chris
Carr Inge chapter 1 hey Google boys all
right so I was able to do a few of the
things which Prabhu mentioned already
right so I was able to log in to Google
home into the application I was able to
search by author names I was able to
search by genres multiple genres so I
said let's get some travel books
let's get them get books on food so if
you see if you heard the response there
when I asked for books on food it said
here are books on eating or cooking
right so it was able to intelligently
get the right type of books right and
then finally we are able to play the
book as well I am able to pause it but
we are also having the capabilities to
do a fast forward rewind start over all
the good things so there are the
features which also are in the pipeline
going to be added like Prabhu mentioned
we should be able to read it at a faster
pace instead of this pace so that's in
the pipeline as well ok so let me start
with what challenges we faced with this
project so when we started the project
so we were told about the scale of the
project how many users were there what
sort of information we had about how
many books were there and the size of
the book for example if you want to play
some of these audio files they are
really large I mean they could be
running in gb
right they are really large books we
have to get the information instantly
there are millions of books it should be
stored it should have various categories
of information like the title you got
various different synonyms possible
you've got author names and then like
Colleen mentioned security is a big deal
we have to make sure that the audio
files that we are using they have to be
secure and they are not accessible by
anybody else other than the patrons who
are already registered with the with the
system and obviously we are have to
target massive scale so that if the
users go beyond millions we have to take
care of that and as the number of books
gets added we have the system in place
which allows the administrators to
seamlessly add those books into the
system make it available right so all
interesting challenges and more
importantly with dialogue flow make it
extremely conversational and intelligent
that's the key here over here so that if
someone even says the wrong things if
the books are not there make sure you
propose new ways of searches or
different intelligent responses that's
the key part right so I'll go with the
high level architecture over here so if
you see there are five bosses the first
two are the channels which are available
for accessing this system you got
support from Google assistant on mobile
and Google home you can use these two
channels or Google vinny as well to
connect to this particular system the
library the conversation management
obviously is being handled by the
dialogue flow engine and finally you got
the fulfillment and that's going to be
handled by the cloud functions that's
what we have used using noches the cloud
functions in turn connect
to the firestore that's where all the
metadata about these books is being
stored so what's the title
what's the author who what are the
chapters there right and then finally
the storage of the audio files itself is
going into Google Cloud storage
so most of the scale issues obviously
we've this is what Google is great at
right I mean it's provide scale so using
the Google flood store if you're very
able to upload terabytes of data
no shoes at all right and we were able
to collect metadata about the books
upload it into the fire store no issues
at all and we this is it's not mentioned
here but we also have to make sure that
the metadata that's getting added into
fire store we have the right jobs which
collect that information and create
intent entities entities out of that and
get it in sync into the dialogue flow so
that's the high level architecture so
let's go into the flow now what exactly
is happening what are the systems being
used out here
so a user speaks into Google home and
the first task that happens there is it
makes sure that the user who has logged
into the Google home you have to set up
Google home and at that point do you
obviously need to sign up right and
that's the information that we are going
to use through the whole system
there's SSO so a single sign-on all over
the place and but the start pointer is
really the authentication into the
Google home so what happens next so a
user speaks into Google home and then
that request goes into the actions on
Google which is the platform that Google
provides for executing your software or
actions on the Google home or the Google
assistant at this point the why is that
the was
according that was done through Google
home is converted into text and then it
goes into the dialogue flow when the
sentence the converted sentence reaches
dialogue flow it's essentially going to
take that sentence convert it into the
intents and extract the entity is
required right once you have the intent
in place we are connected we are
connecting this system to the cloud
function so this information is passed
to the cloud function and that's where
we have intent handlers in place which
are going to read this information and
do the relevant tasks so what is it that
a particular intent is required to do so
let's go to the next slide so suppose we
have to do book search and when you have
to do book search someone is going to
say all right I want to get a book based
on a certain genre so the cloud function
is going to receive that particular
intent which is to search for a book by
a genre and it is going to the firestore
and making sure we have those kind of
books and if it does then it returns
that particular response sends it back
to the dialog flow in text which is then
sent back to the actions on Google and
actions on Google is going to convert
that text into voice and release it back
to Google home so that's the flow for
the typical searches and when you want
to stream the audio the same thing
happens all over the request is going to
the Google home then convert it to the
actions on Google the voice is converted
to the text goes to dialogue flow cloud
function and in the cloud function we
now know that intent is to play an audio
and when you want to play an audio then
you first want to check if that
particular audio file exists or not
so we go to the first or get the
information of whether the audio exists
or not
and once we find that the audio exists
we have systems in place where we have a
mapping essentially that the file which
exists in the fire store we know that
there is a certain file in cloud storage
we go and essentially hit the cloud
storage for and check for that file that
file is being read back and sent to the
actions on Google and that is what is
starting to pretty much play the whole
audio file and once it's raw it takes
over from there and it's playing it's
allowing you to pause fast-forward
repeat start over and all the good
functionalities that actions on Google
provides so for those who want to know
of the technical detail here like I said
there are huge files involved over here
jeebies so one of the big challenge that
we had was all right how do we read this
up like if you're going to read up a
jeebies of data and put it into memory
you know what's going to happen it's
going to crash the system's right so we
have to make sure it's streaming so we
use the media object that actions on
Google provides and luckily that handle
streaming brilliantly we were able to
just go forward to like an hour into the
book and it just continues playing no
issues at all amazing stuff there right
we were able to go back ask it to go
back in time start over no problems at
all so the streaming was a big deal and
luckily the media object that actions on
Google provides handles that beautifully
and like I said the security is another
interesting aspect and I have not really
mentioned that explicitly in the slide
over there but when you hit the cloud
function there's a second level of
security happening over there
so first level is where the Google home
itself is saying that hey I have attend
Takai today it goes to actions on Google
it's authenticated there and then the
SSO passes on and then dialogue flow
says hey we are all good with this user
but when it hits the clouds
function what we do is essentially take
those credentials back especially the
email ID and then in the back end we
have the patrons basically registered so
there's a separate system going in going
to be in place which is registering
these users and the cloud function is
obviously that stored in the firestore
and we are making sure that those users
are authenticated second time right and
only those users can access the files
and again the important thing is since
it's copyright it's stored in the cloud
storage but we need to make sure that
it's not possible to download the files
so it's all being streamed so there's no
chance of these files being downloaded
so those are the details that I wanted
to present the demo the architecture and
the flow with that I'll hand over to Dan
who is going to cover what's the art of
the possible with nano flow yeah thanks
so much good morning everybody so so far
what we've heard we've heard from
Colleen the about the National Library
Service and its mission to enable
reading for the for the blind and
physically handicapped we've heard from
Prabhu Namita about the pilot that we
ran the the various architectures for
that pilot the challenges for that pilot
what I'm going to talk about is going to
be the what I'm going to talk about
we'll be kind of taking this into the
art of the possible what can we do that
we haven't done in the pilot to extend
it and kind of add features that will be
useful for the patrons I will go through
some key features in dialog flow as well
as other use cases that are being used
with dialog flow and we'll also go
through the speech to text and the text
to speech api's briefly again with
highlight of key features and highlight
of case studies that are being used
today so we thought we thought we saw a
cool demo we saw we saw Ramat kind of
tried different things I actually change
up you you heard all the you know arms
and ours and kind of thinking about how
to ask the question kind of all the
things that are inherent in human speech
and when you think about it
when we're saying we want to the
interface to be conversational what
we're saying is I can I can speak in the
affirmative I can answer a question with
yes or I can answer it with absolutely
or sure or definitely or you know let's
go ahead with that and in a in a formal
interactive voice response system it's
gonna be very very difficult for that
system to understand what it is that I'm
trying to say and therefore you need
some system that understands the the
nuance and syntax of the language to be
able to translate that into something
very specific and say get around that my
intent was to move forward my intended
my answer was it was an affirmative so
when we look at when we now look how how
effective was that demo and can can my
patrons can the patrons use that
effectively the first thing we want to
look at is actually something that's
called analytics it's actually available
already today in in dialog flow and when
we scale when we scale the system to
many many users short of just surveying
the users which we certainly want to do
to understand how their experience of
the system wouldn't it be nice if we
could get a flow tree of what are the
intents and by the way when we say
intense we're talking about actions what
is it that I'm trying to do I'm trying
to play a book I'm trying to search a
book where do the users actually focus
so you're seeing here a depiction that
this is a direct from from dialog flow
enterprise and the thicker lines show
you the percentage or the the more
popular flow of that conversation of the
intents and so we know where the users
are navigating today and that gives us a
level of insight into what is being used
or potentially what should be changed or
enhanced in the system how many times do
we fall back into a no-match action and
what do we need to do about that how
many actions how deep do we need to go
from specifying an intent to actually
getting a fulfillment or action behind
it like a playback of a book or or the
list of books that we're looking for so
how deep is this and all that is really
important in understanding your in
understanding the effectiveness of your
model now you also noticed or you may
have noticed that there are sort
floo can support multiple languages this
particular interaction that you heard on
demo was actually set to I'm its
preferences on Google home or
specifically the assistant so so it's
that locale and that dialect can change
to suit the patrons user preferences now
there's a thing called the conversation
style and it would be naive of me to
think that that interaction that you
heard is actually going to serve
everybody you know a full set of diverse
set of patrons and the reason is that
you know we all have slightly different
preferences I mean you saw in the demo
it said you know say one for this book
say two for this book say three for that
book and may or may not like that
interface I may prefer to just say the
name I may prefer maybe when I learn it
I may prefer to just say one or the
first one or the third one and not have
it read out to me that that any that
instruction so the notion of a
conversation style is something that can
be introduced right this is the art of
the possible so to give you a quick
example on the one end of this I might
have a very verbose conversation right
the the assistant the dialogue flow app
comes and says what do you want to read
I have books of this kind I have books
of that kind these are the types of
instructions you can give me so I can
help you find your book when you when
you select make a selection just like we
heard with Ahmed when he selected Pride
and Prejudice the system came back and
said you've selected Pride and Prejudice
is that correct
and he could say yes it is correct so
and I'm a first-time user of the system
I want to get that comfort that the
system understands me right and it knows
what it is that I'm trying to do on the
flipside I might be an experienced user
I want to cut to the chase don't don't
give me all this info let's just play
this with this book think of shortcuts
think of single utterances so how can I
design a system that based on my user
preferences will give me the interface
that best suits me okay and that's what
we were talking about with
conversational styles now book
collections think of it much like a wish
list or a recommendation engine right so
as a user we've already said as a patron
I will log in I will authenticate that
kind of proves Who I am we know that
I've been eligible for the program
we know that's important
for digital rights management
perspective or purposes and when I when
I create a book collection when I say
recommendation engine the first thing a
tech audience will say is yeah we know
what that means
absolutely but in reality here what you
have is the patrons have a very personal
relationship in many cases with their
local librarians as Colleen mentioned
they actually get that they they rely on
their guidance and knowledge and and and
and they they appreciate that but what
we can do here potential is have these
local librarians insert books into your
wish list
so that you have you still maintain that
personal interaction but but but move
forward with you you can still augment
your system-generated recommendations or
personally inserted notes the other
thing is to be able to add annotations
and notes to the book so if for this
perhaps I'm doing some some kind of
study think of a study guide where I can
add my own notes and any information and
I want to maintain that alongside that
place in the book so that I can come
back to this later on and perhaps even
search ours later on content searching
so - in the pilot today primarily you
had three things you had the book title
you had author and you had a genre but
what if I want to search for chocolate
cake recipes across a corpus of books of
content so now being able to search
within the book and have it come back
and provide me some options that
certainly art of the possible
dynamically assembling content would be
something similar to what I just
mentioned where I'm taking content from
multiple places every time that mr.
so-and-so has spoken on a particular
topic and I want to get all of those
flipped out basically and created into a
dynamic books and think of it that way
notifications reminders again that could
be a new content available that could be
my my book club book is about to start
reading my class is about to start
just having Google home notify me and
then finally real quick on the art of
the possible is just what happens to me
a lot I started reading a book and then
I get distracted and do three days later
I'm back or maybe two three weeks later
I'm back or maybe even a month later I'm
back
and now I've forgotten everything that
I've read because my memory needs an
upgrade and I just don't remember things
anymore so wouldn't it be nice similar
to TV shows where you see in the last
episode of this this is what happened
wouldn't it be nice if we could actually
go back a couple of paragraphs summarize
that content programmatically and come
back with this is what you read last
just to remind you the context of where
you were and a little bit further into
the future is voice-enabled research
I'll move forward in the interest of
time so we spoke about analytics as well
already but sentiment analysis think
about as the interaction grows and goes
moves forward what kind of information
can I get about the the the language
that is used by the patron and are they
getting frustrated with the interface
again a way for us to very quickly
assess as the the effectiveness of an
interface there are training phrases
that you use with dialogue flow to train
it and that's how you can tell it how to
use different language and very briefly
that the training phrase will actually
be taken by a dialogue flow and it'll
match it to an intent or an action
you're trying to achieve and will match
entities or things that you're talking
about within your conversation it's a
way for you to train something that is
not so formal in terms of the
conversational aspect I'll move forward
past some of the items here maybe touch
on multi-platform real quick there are a
variety of integrations so for example I
could just as well have used alexa
cortana slack Skype Twitter as
integrations into dialogue flow and that
the benefit there is having the same the
same engine behind the scenes but
different interfaces from the patrons
perspective and real quick on to two of
the use cases you're seeing a bunch of
use cases here I'll touch on two real
quick one of them is Starkey Starkey
Hearing technologies it's a company that
makes hearing aids and they they have a
I guess a brand of Livia and Livia AI
hearing aids and they're actually the
worst the world's first health double
hearing aid with embedded sensors and
ái and what they do is they make it easy
for their customers who use their
hearing aids to understand what features
what what settings they can use on their
hearing aids and they actually use
dialogue flow to be able to enable that
setting so they can talk to their app
they have an app called thrive and they
can talk to this app and actually get
enhanced their the settings that make
sense for them through dialogue flow a
second example is a company called poly
dice out of out of Taiwan and what they
did was I they built the social network
to enable users to be able to find and
share recipes literally so find and
share recipes and they're using dialogue
flow why is that interesting well number
one is you can talk to it and you can
tell it this is what I'm looking for
these are my preferences but secondarily
I'm taking those capturing those
preferences and I can create a
recommendation engine behind it for what
recipes I might want to give you or
which users I might suggest you share
your recipe with so so that's a really
interesting so speech API speech API is
actually broken into two pieces speech
to text and text to speech most of these
examples that I'm going to talk about
our speech to text but I will touch on
text to speech as well the ability to
handle single or multi channels the
ability to which basically means that if
I have multiple speakers each one on a
different channel that I'd be able to
take that all in incorporated into a
single transcription of what of what
said the ability to detect the language
so I can actually provide it with a list
of four languages that aren't expecting
and have a detector language and
transcribe on the fly the ability to use
voice models this is very interesting so
you have the ability you know it is is
the source of the audio a phone call is
the source of the audio command is the
source of the of the audio of video and
when you think about it so if it's a
command it's typically kind of a almost
a single utterance or some things will
be a two to ten-second invocation if
it's a phone call it might be say a form
ended conversation and if it's a video
it could be two hours plus alright and
you might you might say then four
minutes on the phone
there's no ways and I might be aging
myself here because I remember I
remember you know phone calls going into
hours and hours way eclipsing the video
having said that the youngsters of today
are loath to speak on the phone in the
first place so I would say it's averages
out nicely right but it but seriously
the the art effect that we're looking
for each of those environments brings a
different collection of artifacts with
it for example the the command is a
single person writing and usually short
utterances the phone call will be to
people but there's static on the line
there might be other things perhaps two
to three people depending on the
conference and a video will bring again
different background noise and a
different context so each one of them
can be handled by different models to
make it more accurate real quick phrase
ins phrase hints is a way for us to
train the dictionary so to speak of the
transcription so we at next we reach we
announced something called anthos
actually and hence though I believe
comes from the Greek word or flower and
thought is a new word maybe my model
doesn't know what it is right well I can
add a phrasing to say when you hear this
don't break it out into an gibberish I
want you to actually say anthos so I'm
gonna give it as a phrase hint for it to
recognize something that I wanted it
could be a word of the mere sentence
I'll just touch on two more here real
quick because I'm running out of time
one of them is speaker Dyer ization so
we talked about multiple channels we
might have four people in a conversation
how do we transcribe that and how do
what are you doing with speakers are
ization is we're actually providing a
speaker number along with though or a
talker number along with the
transcription so you're seeing the
graphic you've got one speaker in red
one speaker in yellow what I'm able to
do is say speaker one said the following
speaker 2 followed up with this response
speaker 1 continued and it can actually
do that for as many speakers as it can
recognize within the channel so as long
as it's not too many and too close it
can do
all right two two quick examples here
one of them is on the speech-to-text
veetc secure is an organ is a technology
organization that makes services for the
hearing impaired or the deaf community
and specifically they had an initiative
where they're helping them find jobs and
go through job fairs and they used a
speech-to-text capability to help the
hearing-impaired actually converse with
their interviewer the second example
would be on the text-to-speech side of
the house you may be familiar with
Ingram content and they're a distributor
of many many books and publications and
what they do is they're actually able to
use text-to-speech to provide audio pre
books previews and readouts of all the
various books that they have so just
again interesting use cases for the
speech-to-text API and with that I will
call on Prabhu to take us through the
take aways thanks Dan
so if you have any questions we are
happy to answer if we don't know Google
home is here so no issues to wrap up
right now first from from a project this
is a one-way technology with one aspect
of it but really understanding the human
interactions like how users will request
for a book request for to play request
for to search having that internal
interactions clearly laid out then
design for scale like you know
implementing a project with like to load
hundred books was is amilia like you
know we want to have the solution to
have the scale and the reach then very
important security these particular
resources are copyrighted not for
everyone to log in and go through it and
then integrations today we want to do
for a certain platform like say Google
home but we want to make it agnostic
like you know if users have their phones
that they have Google assistant with or
any other modes of interaction we want
to have a platform that supports
multiple integrations into it so key
takeaways vice to quickly wrap up Hugh
interactions conversational style design
for scale security built into it and
support for multiple integrations thank
you
[Music]